globalization may have brought consumers
more choice but it's also brought more
surprises and dangers beyond the
packaging manufacturers and merchants
frequently outsource entire product
ranges abroad or components from
multiple locations all imports
substandard low end consumer products
the situation on the global market has
changed completely and we need to have
strong obligations on the manufactures
but also due to the crisis because I
mean the market surveillance authorities
bit the Member States they don't have
enough resources to check every piece of
goods out there and therefore we need to
make sure that the manufactures are
doing a better job than they are today
hence the need to fix legislation dating
from the turn of the century including
better product safety proofing for
children and vulnerable groups
declaration of origin and through
different but connected legislation
better product surveillance mrs. Sheldon
Moses report press comfortably at
committee stage she's hoping to complete
the process before next May's elections
we're going to have that very good
safety net the consumers can understand
where things are manufactured and
whether it has been tested or not but
not everyone was happy the Liberals
voting against arguing the legislation
on new labeling obligations would create
red tape the Sprint BW occur to you that
he caused and landed on him safe see if
a ball hog has its own bomb gig lisa is
a concessional that said he believed the
key to successful consumer product
protection lay with member states
themselves must be a big lug and it's
dusty mark deuber violence / me to
getting basit sent imprisoned up mia
amica charm isn't a flea should mayor
mayor ferry makarov out in two tool next
step before product safety comes to a
vote in plenary session is the start of
hard negotiations with those very member
states